Bake two pies at the same time and then
relax on
pancake pillows.
It's episode 18
of LÜT.
You can also choose to use emoticon
pillows or a True Blood necklace.
If you're a neat freak, protect your tables
with Portal 2 warning sign coasters.
And then store your photos on an SD card,
or in a SD card photo album.
Personally, I just stick one cool pic on my
laptop lid to make it look see-through
or to make myself look X-rayed or bikini-clad.
And these spatulas will make your cooking more super
hero. Deal yourself hand of nostalgia
with these space invader playing cards
and graduate from Bucky Balls too Bucky
Cubes, a bunch of cube magnets only
outdone by the book
HTML for babies. Teach your child letters
and colours while also reminding them
of proper HTML mark-up.
Vat19's H2O candle kit lets you create
a flame
that appears to sit right on top of water,
which is the best kind of light to play
by when messing around with you Fisher
Price classic toy
keychains.
Thrown on a steampunk skeleton t-shirt
and escape the stress of smartphones
with John's phone.
It accepts a SIM card, but all it can do
is call people and receive calls.
Due to its simplicity
its call time lasts six hours and when
it's not in use its battery lasts
3 weeks.
I met PureKatherine
in Chicago last month.
Now, she will cover your shoes or
anything else you'd like in glitter,
a perfectly trade secret protected coat of
glitter that doesn't shed
off.
These Batman clothespins also keep things secure
and this skateboard bench is great for
your bedroom.
Here's a robot you can control with an app
on your phone.
Oh look, cats love it.
But if you cat loves scratching,
let him be a DJ and scratch on a
scratching post turntable.
But if your cat dies, that's okay, because
the airport in Amsterdam have trash cans
for your used pets.
Just kidding. PET means polyethylene
terephthalate, a polymer used in liquid
containers.
But, if you're hungry,
check out Exotic Meat Market.
This service sells
legal meat for you to cook and eat.
Raccoon meat,
llama, bacon made from a black bear, crocodile,
kangaroo and even lion meat.
That's right. For $100 you
can buy three burgers
made out of lion meat.
Lions are not endangered
and these burgers are made from lions
raised in Illinois.
The only part that's a little bit weird is
that when you eat lion
you're eating cat.
Okay, now it's time for the free thing.
I'm gonna let you guys in on a little bit of a Vsauce
secret. FakeNameGenerator.com.
This website will give you a person's
name, it'll make up their address, it'll
make up all kinds of data about them every
time you refresh the page,
but what's fun is that it also generates a
pronounceable,
available ".com" domain name.
And it's this service, by sitting there
and pressing refresh over and over again
that
I used to find Vsauce.com.
I said that's the perfect name and hence
here we are today.
Thank you FakeNameGenerator.com
for giving us Vsauce.
And to all of you out there:
As always,
thank you for watching.
Vsauce, welcome to my hotel room.
As you can see, episode 18 of LÜT is back
up. I'm not really sure what happened to it,
I think it may have been the
international police.
They've been after me all weekend
for stealing the hearts of women
all over Madrid. Seriously, I've got like
a dozen of 'em in this bag stuck in the
mini fridge, it's really gross,
but that shouldn't get in the way of
a bonus item I think that I just found last
night.
A terra cotta pot.
Just kidding. It's also a grill
and the grilling surfaces circles mean
that the grill marks on your food
are polka dots.
Pretty fun, right?